Yeah,
in March last year,
intelligence squared discussed the
future of Afghanistan and what the West
should be doing that if anything
tonight,
we tackle an even more difficult and
more dangerous situation in Pakistan,
born in the trauma of the petitioner,
British colonial India in 1947.
Pakistan has since then struggled to
match what many Pakistan is regard as
its enemy India only in the possession
of nuclear weapons.
Can Pakistan claim parity?
Otherwise it's progress has been holding
democratic government in Pakistan has
often been interrupted by military rule
and half the country was torn away when
because of India's military
intervention.
East Pakistan became the independent
state of Bangladesh.
Now Pakistan is caught up in the west
battle with violent Islamist from the
tribal areas that border Afghanistan.
Pakistan has become by common consent.
The worlds tend to box for while it's
government is allied to the west.
It's population is seating with
anti-americanism.
So what happens now?
Pakistan,
what next?
To answer that question in own way,
we've seven people highly qualified to
give us their opinion.
Each of them will speak from maximum of
nine minutes.
Before I take your questions from the
floor and also from viewers around the
world at the end,
our speakers will sum up very briefly
indeed,
and I'll hope to put a question to you
for sure.
I've had.